We got news about my former place of residence,
actually Deadline reports, a whole new cast
is moving into the Celebrity Big Brother house.
Woo!
I know!
I was in the Celebrity Big Brother house.
First season, got second place.
Yeah, I agree with you,
I should've won.
Fan favorite.
America's favorite player!
It was a nightmare and I was very proud of what I did.
There's me with Julie Chen, look.
Riveting television.
So I'll be tuning in to all the celebrities.
It premieres tonight on CBS.
I'm wondering though.
Oh, for me?
Would you ever consider doing something like this?
Well, if you say something like,
like if I could do it in my apartment
and the other contestants were Barry Manilow
and a bunch of rescue Pomeranians, I'm in.
(all laughing)
Yes, totally.
Barry's playing "Ready to Take a Chance Again"
on the piano and the poms and I are all watching TV.
♪ And I'm ready to take a chance again ♪
♪ Ready to put my love on the line for you ♪
(audience applauding)
You two.
(Bridget laughing)
♪ You get what you get when you go for it ♪
(all laughing)
Okay, by the way, the cast is Lamar Odom-
Yes!
Carson Kressley.
One of my friends.
Teddi Mellencamp, Todrick Hall.
Yes, another friend of mine.
This is a great cast.
I'll be tuning in every single night watching.
Carson seems like such a nice guy.
How's he gonna do in that environment?
It just feels so-
Like get eaten alive.
Dog eat dog, yeah.
Do you want it some insight scoop?
[Drew And Bridget] Yes.
So Carson called me and was like, okay,
you can't tell anybody, but I'm going in.
So I gave him tips to play the game.
I did. Yeah, because I'm good at it!
Hello!
You gotta play the game, you're there to win, right?
Yeah, much like Rudy on the football team.
You're there to win.
That's right!
(all laughing)
And I, you know, I was sorta the Rudy of my season,
except I didn't win.
What is your number one tip?
My number one tip is to remember it's just a game,
but if you're playing a game, you play to win!
Ooo!
(Bridget laughing)
Yeah you do.
I'm like you, were nice.
But if we're playing a game with rules, bring it on!
We wanna win!
That's true.
That is true.
I am very scrappy and frisky.
Just like Rudy.
Just like Rudy!
(all laughing)
And I'm short like Rudy too.
That's right, yeah.
So, all right-
Five foot nothin'!
A hundred and nothin'!
But here you are gettin' a degree from Notre Dame,
the best university in the country!
Yes!
(audience applauding)
Except, you know.
(Bridget laughing)
By the way, if you can watch Rudy and not cry
you're not alive.
Yeah, you're not alive.
All right Bridget, you've got the next story.
All right good, I don't have my glasses
but let me see what I can do here.
Okay.
(audience laughing)
I went from 20/20 to practically blind.
Okay, we've got a new dating tactic you can find
only on TikToK.
The New York Post reports, a woman named Sophia Franklin,
says she likes to keep her date on their toes
by secretly sending herself a drink.
She pretends it's from a secret admirer
somewhere else in the restaurant, just to let her date
know that she is in demand.
Drew-
Whoa!
Would you do that?
You know, it's so funny.
It's like, I don't think I'm clever and crafty enough,
but would you ever do this?
Absolutely,
because I feel like
(all laughing)
if I'm sitting there with somebody,
I don't know that's in my inner circle.
I will be very stressed out
and I will want another cocktail.
So I will use the excuse that it's from a secret admirer.
But that secret admirer is me.
And I'm just tryin'-
Wow!
To treat myself right.
No, listen.
I think this is nuts to send yourself a drink,
pretending that somebody-
What?
Ooh!
(all applauding)
Where did this come from?
You guys, thank you. I don't know where this came from.
Thank you so much!
(all laughing)
Oh, that's good!
Thank you whoever sent this, thank you.
Oh my God,
(all laughing)
that is hilarious, Ross.
All right, well next we've got
a spicy little fashion throwback that's rising back up.
Marie Claire reports that this year
it is all about the thong thong, thong, thong, thong.
Ew!
That's right.
You know, it's all about that thong.
(Ross laughing)
Okay, well, back in the day you had Christina Aguilera,
Julian Anderson.
Oh, that was the look.
Oh yeah, I remember that Christina-
Halle Berry, and today now J-Lo, Bella Hadid,
and Alexa Demie, all giving panty cleavage.
Yeah.
Love it or leave it, Bridget?
I wouldn't do with a thong.
I would do my full coverage
(all laughing)
and I would yank it up,
slide my arms underneath it,
(all laughing and clapping)
pop it over and have to sort of the very central,
sort of like J-Lo with the thong,
but J-Lo with that VMA dress, you know, that Versace dress.
Yes!
So that's just my underwear over the shoulders
(all laughing)
and the jeans.
Well mine are big enough that if you were at Notre Dame,
(all laughing)
and you were at one of the games,
you could do just like Lady Gaga in the halftime show.
You know how she like sort of flew from the sky.
I would just like take my underwear
(Bridget flapping lips)
and just like fly down and drop into a championship game.
(all laughing and applauding)
I love it! I love it! I love it!
All right, we have to go to a quick commercial break.
Come right back, we have more Drew's News.
(upbeat music)